bonifacio es un expreso político y
víctima de la tortura bajo la ley
marcial impuesta en 1972 en filipinas la
cual suspendió los derechos
constitucionales de la población además
de otorgar nuevas facultades a la
policía y fuerzas armadas y lo que
sirvió para justificar la persecución
contra los opositores
experience
experimente horas de tortura
me pusieron una plancha en las plantas
de mis pies y me pusieron balas entre
los dedos y me apretaban tan fuerte las
manos bullets que sentía que mis huesos
se rompían 2 hansen squeeze my hands of
time directa además screaming pain las
torturas fueron escalando incluso
llegaron a afectar los genitales de este
sobreviviente pero no fue lo único que
ha tenido que sobrellevar su hermana
desapareció en esa época y piensa que es
uno de los casos de ejecución
extrajudicial de la dictadura no
coincide que pueda volver el clan marcos
al poder the sun of the dictator became
president el hijo del dictador se
convierte en presidente después de 50
años después de que su padre haya
gobernado bajo la ley marcial la verdad
que es impensable en carbón durante las
dos décadas de mandato del ex dictador
ferdinand marcos las fuerzas de
seguridad mataron torturaron abusaron
sexualmente de los presos y también los
mutilaron amnistía internacional estima
que se detuvo cerca de 70 mil opositores
además su esposo y partidarios probaron
a las arcas
aproximadamente 10 mil millones de
dólares ningún miembro de su familia fue
encarcelado